alright we've taken a break to regain
our composure after that last caller
we're gonna jump back on the phones at 6
1 7 8 3 0 47 50 next caller from the 911
caller from 91 to name and where you're
calling from please and by all means
jump right into your question hey David
my name is Tyrone I'm calling from
Savannah Georgia ok so basically yeah
basically I had a question about the
bell curve so you know I run or I'll
follow a lot of people in a skeptic
community or in Twitter and there's a
whole bunch of you know there's a lot of
divide in the community when it comes to
bell curve so what you're talking about
just Tyrone people who don't know you're
referring to race and IQ generally that
right is that right correct okay
correct yes so are you I see people like
Sam Harris who you know it gives you
know the little validity to the study
and then you see I see a lot of people
on the far left they you know there's no
you know it's not really validated but I
can't seem to find any studies that
really refute it um you know like I just
wanted to know what's your opinion on
the whole thing so listen this is a
nuanced thing and for people who don't
know the bell curve is a book by charles
murray which argues that there are IQ
divisions among racial lines i don't
think you would be shocked to hear what
the different sort of ranking of race
IQs is in that book he was recently
recently interviewed by sam harris on
sam Harris's podcast it created a huge
stir we're actually working on a deep
dive long-form video into race and IQ
Tyrone and I couldn't possibly sum that
up here but there's a couple things that
people need to be aware of number one
when it comes to IQ tests you often hear
two views on IQ tests either the IQ is a
great indicator of true intelligence in
individuals that's sort of like one side
the other side is IQ tests are totally
worthless at measuring any kind of
intelligence because they are culturally
biased and
among lines of social class or whatever
and usually you will see one side merely
discredit the hundred and eighty degree
oppose position the truth is that IQ
tests can give us insight into a certain
type of intelligence there are problems
with IQ tests and they also don't relate
to the only type of intelligence so the
truth is often sort of in the details
you know but the other thing that I
would encourage our audience in advance
of our long-form piece about this to
think about is even if you could
definitively prove in what would we we
would all agree on is a sort of
legitimate scientific way that you see
differences of average IQ among race
does that prove that the IQ differences
are because of race and I think Tyrone
you'll understand why that second
question is sort of like the key
question if we're even going to have a
serious conversation about this there's
other factors like you know the
environment you grow up in right exactly
exactly so listen I think that I don't I
don't want to say too much more now
because we are working on this long-form
piece but I've not been ignoring the
issue I am interested in it I just want
to make sure that we treat it seriously
and sort of do like once and for all
this is the deal with this topic type of
thing and it's coming up soon so you'll
see it alright thanks Tyrone great to
hear from you from Savannah Georgia I
think he said I've never been to
Savannah but I hear it's beautiful
I hear it I hear is absolutely stunning
down there